It's story time.
"Best Daddy in the World" by Alyssa Liang.
I love my Daddy.
I want him to sleep in on Father's Day.
I will do all of his Sunday chores for him.
Daddy drives his car to work during the week.
He washes his car on Sunday.
I wash his car for him on Father's Day.
Daddy mows the lawn on Sunday.
He keeps the lawn nice and tidy.
I mow the lawn on Father's Day.
Daddy makes breakfast on Sunday.
He likes pancakes.
I make pancakes for Daddy on Father's Day.
Daddy picks up his newspaper on Sunday.
He reads the newspaper after breakfast.
I pick up the newspaper for him on Father's Day.
I do all the chores for Daddy this morning.
Daddy and I can have fun together for the rest of the day.
We play basketball in our backyard.
We bike to the park.
We fly a kite.
We paddle on the lake.
We have a great day.
I give Daddy a big hug.
I whisper into his ear.
You are the best Daddy in the world.